you look at this you think this is the
last question this is better to have
some kind of I know the baby it's not as
bad as it looks it does look a little
weird i'll admit because you've got your
shine 45 and you're thinking you should
have something to the for like you're
thinking reverse chain rule okay but
they give you a clue to actually tell
you you're not going to necessarily
leave that okay soon and give you this
substitution let's see how far we can
take it in order to solve this question
ok so if they've done that we're
integrating right the very first thing
you should do with this substitution is
you should differentiate it okay because
we can't substitute just yet so if i
take to you on DX what's that equal to
its just caught isn't it okay there you
can do see two different ways you could
either say d u is equal to cos x DX and
that's okay right the reason why that's
okay to say is because i had a deer to
the Cossacks in there I had more than
those well but I have at least that
alternatively you might prefer to make
Dexter subject and I think you'll get do
you / cos x because you just be dividing
through okay now you might prefer that
because you can just substitute
Australian and see what happens I
differentiate it I can get rid of this
I've got this substitution I can get rid
of this there's one more piece I need to
get rid of actually it's kind of too but
there's one that's obvious what am I
missing but haven't I got rid of you
it's a damaged or right definitely
gorgeous so I've got these zeros and
piles or two so I've got angles because
I got trig functions make sense but if
i'll go to move all this stuff into you
right these are x batteries so I've got
to change never tease you batteries as
well so we'll just do that very quickly
just to reiterate you don't have to draw
the table but it's kind of useful
sometimes 0 to PI on to is going to
correspond to this is sign right so
that'll be trans the terrible
that's 0 to 1 I think sign a player 2 is
one ok so let's rewrite this now this is
one of those tricky examples where what
we try to do is get rid of all the X's
and replace them all with use right and
you can do that in this question but
it's a little hard to see so I'm going
to be a bit naughty and do it in pieces
i'm gonna do a pathway so zero player 2
becomes 0 1 so the 5x just becomes you
25 ok now this this guy i have not
resolved here ok I'll go in this way
because I see that's what a lot of you
I've done so I'm just going to follow
that method even though this would work
fine I don't have anything yet that will
get rid of work clothes cubed ok so i'm
just going to write him down this is the
gaudy bit we try to avoid that don't
like using it but I've got like dat ok
so that's do you move up cos x at least
that's the substitution I've chosen ok
so remember my goal is to get rid of all
the x's I'm changing this into a
different kind of question right so the
first thing I can do is well I can get
rid of that cos x and I get a 2 there
right does it look like it's much better
because I still have all of this cosine
in there but I can do something with
this I could do something with cos
squared because I need to get in terms
of sides but you can do that right what
identity will you use you use the other
day right use the Pythagorean so we're
used to saying side squared plus cos
squared equals 1 right so therefore you
can't a off that cos square is equal to
1 minus that ok so I'm going to use that
here so 0 to 1 you to the five this is
one minus sine squared X do you ok and
now at last I can actually get rid of
all my exes ok so I'm body this as you
so I'm just going to go
not 21 that's what minus u squared okay
this is just a polynomial I can do this
it's not bad our bodies will just expand
it quickly that's you to the five even
seven yep you can go from there let's
just quickly get the value I shall we
this is going to become you to the six
on six this is going to become you that
ain't on eight and I'm going from not 21
so I've got a sixth minus f minus zero
which i think is whatever so what was
tricky about this question who is that
all of this stuff which usually gets rid
of all of the pieces here wasn't quite
enough you have these leftover bits okay
but number one they gave you this crew
so you're like ok at least I know I'm
headed in the right direction so it's
not like I picked some burgers method
unlike you know earlier those question a
question to part a and if you didn't use
T results you could still get it but
you'd go round and round in circles but
I didn't tell you to use T results right
here they did tell you what method to
you so you had to have a little bit of
faith that it was going to work out in
the end okay but it's it's not so bad
remember the goal is just get rid of all
of one variable to third of all the
other and you